this film really caught me I was really
into kales journey and I was really
amazed because when we were doing it we
were never aware of the camera or what
the camera was doing so when when we
finally got to sue it I was released
impressed with what Alfonzo was was
seeing when it comes to yelitza
and working with her what did you learn
from her I know she's the first time
actress but I'm sure you guys learn from
each other I learned a lot I mean she
has a beautiful way of just being
herself her beautiful self she's an
incredible human being really open with
a soul that shines and for me she was
always Cleo I was never thinking if she
was the first time actress or a non
actress or or if she had or not previous
experience she was killed you are
opening so many doors I want I talk to
Marina and she said that she learned so
much from you what have you learned from
her for Anita setting it up get DNA they
have la Frontera cameras porque el - yo
soy muy tarde ver como se controller
yeah but I low growl job Alfonzo and
marina have nothing but great things to
say about you how has this whole
experience changed your life for the
better
Ingres our la pasion sierra lo que
realmente nunca - el oportunidad de son
Arlo's por que estar amazon focus on a
studio
trabajar porque consider avec al Sur
actress era como algo imaginary o una
elección salami
[Music]
and then your character is a mother that
is just doing everything she can to
raise her children and she's making
sacrifices how do you relate to your
character
I relate a lot I mean I I have a son I'm
also a single mom and I was raised by a
mother that had to go through the things
that Sophia had to go through and I
think there's lots of mothers that that
face that they have to be the head of
their families and raise children by
themselves so for me it's really
important to have the opportunity to
talk about these things and to think
about what we need to do with um with
feathers these guys are getting all of
this award show and and these accolades
are ready how would you react to winning
an Oscar or being nominated all these
awards just I mean I just see them as a
great gift that I never even dreamed of
do you have a speech prepared or what
would you want to say onstage yo
estoppel is con todo lo que estaba
viviendo con cada uno de estos momentos
por que se que significa demasiado para
la gente de de mi Pais es es esta Puerta
demostrar que el mundo la diversidad que
tenemos in in Mexico y el mismo tiempo
mostrar lagos que también podemos sonya
yank and charlotta came
[Music]